thank you rocky work accidents can  happen at any time but what are some  things you should do in case you are a  victim of one eric palacios from eric  palacios and associates the sponsors of  this segment tell us more  welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney  eric palacios today we're going to tell  you three things you need to do if you  suffer a work injury  number one be sure to report it to a  supervisor immediately it's best to have  confirmation and this can be done with a  text or an email number two seek medical  attention as soon as possible although  you have 90 days to see a doctor the  longer you wait the worse it is for your  claim  number three tell the doctor or the  medical staff that you were injured at  work this way the doctors will fill out  the correct forms to protect your claim  this has been the legal minute don't  forget to download